now protesters in Lebanon have been out
on the streets once again issuing a new
call for action following three months
of anti-government unrest they've
regrouped what they call a week of anger
under the slogan the revolution is
coming back on Tuesday night protests in
the capital Beirut turned violent
what say no hado joins us live now from
the Lebanese capital Zana so last night
a main commercial district in the
capital was a battleground we know there
had been violent incidents since the
protest movement began and so was last
night different anger is escalating
people are growing increasingly
frustrated because of the near economic
collapse in the country as you can see
behind me banks have been vandalized
cash machines destroyed Hamra these in
central Beirut a commercial district was
a battleground for hours they were
running battles between security forces
and protesters which began outside the
Central Bank a few hundred meters from
where we are standing protestors tried
to storm the Central Bank and security
forces intervened people are angry
because the banking sector they've
imposed capital controls basically
there's only a certain amount of money
you can withdraw from your savings
dollars are in shortage and there's even
a cap on the amount of Lebanese pounds
so people feel the banking sector is
keeping people's the money hostage and
they're also blaming the banks for the
failed policies in a recent years that
led to Lebanon's worst economic crisis
in decades but at the same time some of
the protesters who were on the streets
yesterday are supporters of the ruling
Alliance and many believe that this was
a message a message to the banking
sector as well as the head of the
central bank that they want him to go
for two reasons those in the ruling
Alliance those who hold power in this
country believe that banks in one way or
the other are imposing this controls to
create more anger in the street and to
turn the street against those in power
the political class and it's not just
that they do blame riyadh salami for
implementing US sanctions against the
Iranian backed with Hezbollah which
leads the
Alliance Oh a political message at the
same time Zana just briefly is there any
sign the political vacuum will end any
time soon to allow the economy to
improve
no politicians are in deadlock they are
vying over ministerial seats bickering
amongst each other a Prime Minister was
appointed approximately a month ago
Hassan dia by the ruling Alliance who
now don't seem to want him
Hassan dia has a cabinet lineup what we
understand of technocrats independent
experts which is what the street wants
what the anti-establishment protesters
want but right now those in power are
insisting on keeping their political
power because of regional developments
following the killing of the Iranian
military commander Qasem Soleimani many
people here believe Lebanon is going to
be in the eye of the storm because the
ruling elite is led by a group allied
with Iran so they want politicians in
the next government in case certain
decisions have to be made and now they
want the man they appointed out of
office and that is why they have joined
the anti political establishment
protesters in the streets
all right Isaiah Hoda there in Beirut
zina thank you